this is a production of Cornell
University
uh so today I'm going to be talking
about what we've been learning about
gravis from the Grapevine genome and
before we start because not of all of
you some of you I know but not all of
you are familiar with grapevines I have
a sort of a primer of grape genetics
here that will help you understand at
least guide through the the next minutes
of my presentation so we talk about
gravis at least on the west coast and
the rest of the world we're talking
about a single species light is vinifera
okay which is quite remarkable you know
probably the most important food cup in
the world and what relying 95 on a
single species so this single species
species bite is the difference
suspicious sativa
is um hermaphroditic so it has perfect
flower with both functional male and
female parts
and was domesticated from populations
they were actually their issues with
plants carrying either male or female
flowers
and therefore they were obligated
outcasting wild progenitors these bite
is to speak
are technically capable of of selfing
however we don't typically propagate
grapevines by Surfing by collecting the
seeds from their food because we want to
maintain genetic identity and also
because Grava is deriving from these
obligately outcasting population they
suffer of genetic load and in breathing
depression in case of self so typically
Graven cultivars are both f1s of distant
related parents to deal with the high
recessive load in in gravis and they're
also currently propagated to maintain
their genetic identity okay uh
unlike
what we cultivate there is plenty of
wild species around around the world and
some of them are in North America and
I'm going to talk about that turbo the
end of my talk these whitest pieces are
the issues but they're also
inter-fertile this interfertility
between white species confounds a little
bit what we call species in the genus
bites but has a very important
evolutionary implications because those
population either in the past or in the
present coexist so there is plenty of
gene flow and integration processes that
lead to Adaptive adaptation and
evolution
and uh finally not to forget there is
some five percent of the VT culture made
with other species other hybrids either
hybrids between vinifera and other white
species or entirely other species now to
forget those and some of them I use a
rooster so guy Vines our white is
benefit is typically grafted onto root
stocks that provide protection to soil
burner issues pest diseases as well as
pH conditions and other so
done with the primer of game genetics
we're done and this should help a little
bit guide you through the different
parts of my talk I will start talking a
little bit about what we've learned
about a guide genomes by assembling and
studying them
um the importance of Grapevine
intercosity so remember we have
domesticated gravis selecting those
individuals very hermaphroditic in these
high literozygous population of obligate
outcasters okay so heterozygous it
exists also in our germ plasma material
we use for cultivation we don't we don't
grow in breads we don't grow nearly
isogenic blinds we grow f1s and those
f1s are highly terrorizers and we're
going to see how important it is when we
study grapes and then I will touch a
little bit about uh North American Wild
Whitey species and how we've been using
the genetic information on North
American species to create a vitis pan
genome and if the time allows I will
attach a little bit on our effort to
make all the genomic information we have
developed in the recent years publicly
available
Okay so
this is uh in a slide the history of
grave genomics that started about 2027
2007 when
The pn40024 genome was assembled and
released to the public uh you probably
don't recognize this as a cultivar I
don't drink wine from a pn20024 you may
recognize the end stands for Pinot Noir
so it's an inbred line derived from
Pinot Noir it was created specifically
for genome sequencing because of the
issue of terrazygosity which which is
pretty much in the way always when we do
genomics the scientists in in France and
Italy they generated this inbred line
partially in red line to produce the
first genome and as you can see there is
kind of a lag period which is not
uncommon in Plants where the first model
genome is developed and then because of
farming or because of technological
limitations we don't explore genomic
diversity and until really until 2015
with the um when long read sequencing
came in then we start seeing an
exponential uh increase in the available
genomes and of course with genomes comes
also knowledge of the genetics of these
of these species
so I would say that this explanation
increases pretty much due to the
introduction of long grid sequencing so
pack bio in particular at the very
beginning
that allows of course to generate more
contiguous genomes but I'm going to show
in a second also genomes the carry solve
heterozygous regions uh capability of
sequencing full-length transcripts and
we push a little bit the the boundaries
here by
incorporating genetic information to
generate uh homologous chromosome
information I'm going to show in a
second and finally the ability of
actually analyzing diploid genomes so
uh most of you must be familiar with the
longer it sequencing and how how they
actually changed the availability of of
genomes however every species of plant
Etc had the opportunity to have a new
genome long grades allowed to generate
more contiguous genomes
the beauty of of this system is that we
can also what we call phase so construct
regions that uh face the homologous
regions initial heterozygous regions in
a genome so at the end of the day what
we were able to construct at the very
beginning were what we call primary
assemblies as well as Assemblies of the
terozygous regions providing access to
the alternative information on those on
those regions as I mentioned we we
pushed a little bit in the past few
years to go from Context or from
fragmented assemblies to chromosome
scale assemblies and we did this by uh
using the vitis core consensus map
developed as part of itsgen too
to construct
to both gain contiguity so build
composite molecules but also to use the
reciprocal appetite information to build
the diploid genomes which we're gonna
I'm gonna show in a second uh why
they're so important for what we want to
do
uh this is one of our first the Cabernet
genome just to point out that is always
good to integrate information so for a
while in the lab we're using bio
sequencing in parallel with Optical
mapping to build the hybrid assemblies
that then with our Apple sync tool we
will be able to assemble in Phase
chromosomes this is quite outdated
already because of the introduction of
High Fidelity sequencing
and this is a paper we released uh this
year or last year where we actually show
that yes uh Hi-Fi based commercial scale
deployed assemblies can be generated and
can be also faced by using parental
information because we looked at the
genomes of three root stocks that are
hybrid of two of two of these pieces and
the third one so by shared parentage
will be able to assign hublotypes to one
or the other parent and phase the deploy
genomes
okay so we have the tools and uh
by by using these tools
one of the first observation which I'll
skip this in a second is
the high degree of structural
variability so by looking at markers it
was clear that of course
cultivars and wild species
etceterozygous and by looking just at
the sequence so single leucotype
polymorphisms we can talk about over two
percent of our zygosity what we what
became clear early on when we started
generating the first and the second and
third the very beginning genomes is that
we found a very high extremely high
structural type of psychosity so when we
talk about structural variability we
talk about insertion deletions
translocation Etc that impact the
structure of the chromosomes
when we compare homologous chromosomes
okay so within each of this genome we
find the homologous chromosome differ by
20 and of course being most of the the
cultivar related to one another we we
see the same degree of structural
variability between cultivars
so about 20 percent of the genome being
uh heterozygous at the structural level
and of course this this makes sense
for the reason I presented before makes
sense because we domesticated
individuals coming from these obligated
outcasting populations makes sense
because our great cultivars are F1
crosses we need to we need to breed
varieties by by Crossing distant species
to limit in building the pressure
the third one it was not so clear at the
point was that also coronal propagation
has a has an effect and I will not touch
this today but just keep in mind that
data or zygosity that we selected during
domestication has been exacerbated by
hundreds of years of Chrono propagation
for example is a cross between cap Frank
and sauvignon blanc the cross was made
accidentally on purpose around the 1650s
since then Cabernet Sauvignon has been
chronically propagated which means that
mutation have been accumulating over
over the cycles of vegetative
reproduction but never been exposed to
sexual reproduction
sogosity accumulated by uh some somatic
variation is never being removed
selected in those small uh chronal
cronal selection programs were never
removed by sexual reproduction so
and we think that some of these 20
percent of whatever psychology that we
find in the cultivated cultivas is is a
terozygous or not phylotypically visible
but due to this somatic somatic
variation
um and and I'm gonna just touch a little
bit a couple of examples why having
information on diploid uh chromosome is
important this is how typically a
diploid Commerce genome looks like with
apple type 1 2 for each of the 19
chromosomes of grape here and now just
by looking at the information this
provides well we're doubling basically
the gene space we are observing and
again we're dealing with the
haliterozygous species which means that
we have the opportunity to look at
different alleles okay analyles count
and I have just one simple example here
when we look at carmener Carmenere is a
French variety of nowadays mostly
cultivated in Chile famous for his uh um
green bell pepper Aromas that are due to
the combination of oxy piercings
the key step in the most potent methoxy
periods in accumulation is is uh
catalyzed by these metal transference
well when we look
at this Gene family was studied before
us but we could find the four Parallax
of the gene family for each parallelog
we have the diploid information we found
the two alleles okay so for rnt2 we have
two nt1 Etc de omt3 which is the one
expressing fruit and we're not
responsible for this key step
is it the interesting thing is that the
two leaves have very different catalytic
properties which means that if you are a
student you want to look at the omt3 of
Carmen air and understand how methoxy
piercing accumulate and you pick the
wrong allele the allele that is actually
has much lower uh catalytic capacity to
catalyze that reaction you will be very
unlucky so depending on the Lil
you may have different biochemical
outcomes
another example I have here is
known for a long time to have two low
side of resistance for powdery mildew
uh
we knew that there were two loci and we
also thought that these resistance was
homozygous because you make crosses you
look at the phenotypes and the the
flanking markers are homozygous the
phenotype is homozygous well their
resistance homozygous when we look
actually at the two loci reconstructed
both run one and round two loci in this
species we found that each Locus is uh
heterozygous and the content on mbslrs
is very different actually none of the
genes are conserved across the two okay
so this means that now one single
accession muscadine
carries four low sides of resistance
because two are heterozygous
again this was possible because we
constructed the diploid genome for this
particular species now I have an example
that actually looks at the domestication
so
I mentioned before
our cultivated gryvines are methodox
hermaphrodites which means they form
these perfect flowers where you have a
functional pistil and functional
stomachs
this type of flower
is not frequently found or is very
rarely found in natural populations that
are actually the issues or you have
flowers actually look perfect because
you have both male and female parts but
as you can appreciate here for example
in the female flowers the Pea still is
there and functional stamens are
reflexed you cannot see that but the
pollen grains are also non-fertile so
female flowers morphologically may be
hermaphrodites but functionally actually
female
male flowers the Pea still is there
but is not fully developed
interesting enough female flowers cannot
revert to male flowers under any
condition because the pollen grains are
known fertile however male flowers under
certain condition of stress or or other
kinds they can actually develop a
functional pistil which you know the
theory makes sense that if you're a male
and you don't have any female around and
you need to reproduce sexually you can
you can if you can actually revert to a
female flower you can make seeds and and
fruit and attract the cities personal
agents and still reproduce sexually Okay
so we were very interested in
understanding the genetic basis of this
process both the process of uh
development of the issues the population
form ancestral and methodism and as well
as how grapevines
doing domestication were selected by
covering hermaphroditism and as you can
see 2020 was a shitty year for many
reasons but for for this topic actually
it was a position also shitty because
there was a lot of competition but but
it was a good year so we had a lot of
insights in the uh in this locals doing
those those couple of years so going
back to um what we knew before all those
studies well
most of plants most of flowering plants
are hermaphrodite so
the presence of female and male flowers
on separate individuals
is an acquired trait okay so the
ancestors ancestral state is
hermaphroditism
so what happens in this population that
we were fully hermaphrodite
the first step is the acquisition of
male sterility recessive
so that by selfing only you will
generate
female
that coexist with other hermaphrodites
the second step of this process of
development of the issues population
requires the form the presence of
another mutations which is the mutation
that leads to a dominant female
suppressing suppression which means that
at this point
the female expression is suppressed
and all these dominant recessive was
modeled before actually knowing knowing
what genes Etc were involved and then
finally very important was hypothesized
that the recombination event rare
recombination event of the functional
male and functional female alleles
happen during domestication that
resulted in in hermaphroditic flowers
okay so we start from aphrodites we
build the issues populations by two-step
and then we buy a combination we recover
the hermaphroditism okay so that was the
model and uh us and others before us
Define sexual determination in a single
Locus on chromosome 2 and this is from
us but it repeats pretty much what other
I have done before so at that point when
we publish actually the Chardonnay
genome 2019 we had available the
pn40024 genome apploid so this derived
from Pinot Noir Pinot Noir we know is
heterozygous for hermaphoricism so is
what we think is a hermaphoreticalil and
a female allele
so just one at least represented in this
genome which allele we didn't know yet
we knew genetically that is homozygous
hermaphrodite cabernetes
and so at this stage we adjust this
stage you know to compare the first
thing we did we compare Chardonnay one
of the two apple types with Pinot
doesn't matter because we know that this
is homozygous for this trade
and we're already observed some
differences you know this these ones
that are highlighted for example these
genes were not present in the Pinot
reference
okay interesting but it could be by you
know technical issues or whatever
um so the other thing we had we had the
replication of the Apple type h because
of Chardonnay being a mosaicos We
compare the two upload types that we
find so these diagrams are all genes and
we find that the genes were not found in
the Pino genome were actually present in
both both Applause becoming you know at
least based on this observation good
candidates for uh hermaphoricism at
least because HH is is the uh that lives
in
is an HF
clearly we had in our hands and
hermaphrodite haplotype
equal engine content to the Chardonnay
aplotype and the other haplotype smaller
with the with a smaller number of genes
very similar to the
um this is artificial believe me this is
the female aplotype engine content is
the same as the Pinot reference the
structure is different because apploid
by by forming this upload genome they
they create a sort of a hybrid
assembly between the female and their
methodistic uh
aplotypes anyways so
this was the first observation but there
are limits here there are limits because
we don't have the male upload type
and uh very little replication of course
so we extended observation to a a larger
number of accessions
uh both from the domesticated cultivars
all these hermaphrodites from for
domesticated ones then the male male
females from from Sylvester's so the
natural the wild population from from
which uh benefit was domesticated as
well as Arizona so
which are both male they're looking here
about between 20 40 million years of
evolution okay separating
from fromvitis
um so each of these uh line we sequence
and faced in the sex Locus
carry two apple types so the male will
be male female aplotypes uh the female
female both recessive and then
hermaphrodites either HF or HH I don't
have an HH there that's part another
story anyways so we have basically 22
upload types to compare
and first of all talking about
structural variability what was very
interesting despite the fact we were
looking about as I said 20 million years
of split when we look at the
um
the the female Applause for example
very concerned
so this is the female type of all those
uh 22 apotex compared to cabernetes very
concerned
male aplotypes
I'm going to show you in the next Slide
the genic genic information is extremely
conserved 100 conserved structurally
wise we have a large inversion in
muscular and grapes and insertion in
Arizona okay so more variable than a
female applicant
the HR prototype of course because of
the bottleneck due to domestication very
conserved also we didn't sample hundreds
like we did later
but very concerned okay so first
observation structural variability
defines the different Apple types and
within Apple type we have extreme
conservation despite the long uh time
we're looking at
Gene content again
so much time to go through everything
but when when we compare the haplotypes
across all the
benefit the male and the female Etc the
gene content is a hundred percent
concerned hundred percent concerned even
in the presence of what we observe this
individual pseudogenes present only in
the female haplotypes but in a hundred
percent of them so every single female
Applause had a pseudogene they were
actually functional in their male and
hermaphrodite
aplotypes this was interesting candidate
because it was shared as a pseudogene
across all the females
and the pseudogene the mutation
occurring and forming the pseudogene is
the same one those eight base pair
missing in all the female aplotypes
they're actually present in all the hmas
so these eight base pair despite the
fact here we're looking at mustadine
arizonica so again 20 million years of
of Separation those eight base per
nucleotides are shared by all the female
applicants
and this was an interesting candidate
for us because okay we validated with
other markets in other accessions was
interesting because in arabidopsis the
ortholog imp1 it stands for in aperture
pollen one is a gene that has been shown
when mutated to um
induce the lack of this uh
copai this opening that that allow
pollen grains to emerge from the the
pollen tubes to emerge from pollen
grains and in fact when we look at male
sterile grapes the pollen don't form
these these structures so this is our
candidate we're working now on The
Knockouts to show actually we can
reproduce male stability by knocking out
the gene the other interesting Gene we
found is one single Gene
in this region of the applied that was
actually the one that carried
the only known synonymous nibs
across all the males and not in the
female and hermaphrodites so remember
the female sterility derives from a
dominant male gin
okay so this became our candidate
this is became our candidate for male
for female sterility
and they also organizik supported uh the
discretion the highest profession only
of this habitation factor in the males
and we did transgenic and when we look
at a transgenic
we did transgenic with antibacter the
female allele of this yabitation Factor
doesn't cause any change
any visible morphological change to the
flower over Express in the male
counterpart what we think the dominant
male allele that result in a lack of
expression of female
we have astronomical statements highly
uh
impaired in their development pistols
and sometimes you know
the flowers don't open so the the petals
contain in as seen here they contain
only all this damage so clearly in
Alteration in sex morphology due to the
expression of this candid Gene
they um of course the limitation to this
in particular is the other expression so
remember I told you the beginning that
male flowers can refer to female flowers
it's likely that the expression of the
yabby modulates that capability of
reverting to one or the other sex and by
overexpressing it we're really messing
up with the with the morphology of the
flowers so we're doing more more
experiments and one of them is using DNA
Affinity purification sequencing where
basically we look where those yabi bind
in the genome to identify the data
visual network of the abigins and we did
this both with the female and male
allele
this is what puzzled me at the beginning
we have 187 genes that bind to the
female lead consistently cross
replicates as well as Mela leaves
same number and when I see say numbers
in biology I don't believe it because it
cannot be but uh it looks like the 75
again seven numbers same numbers but
unique genes are associated with the
male and female allele and we're now
looking at what what these genes are and
uh and follow up and I have this picture
showing actually you know see much here
but the mutation doesn't help us because
it occurs in the inter-domain for which
we have very low confidence by just
predicting the protein structure so we
cannot really tell how the protein
functionality changes in in as a
consequence of that
single nucleotide polymorphism and amino
acid change
okay so I still have time yeah so now a
little bit about our effort to look at
the North American bites genomes why
North America well uh
one of the centers of diversity of itis
30 species and very interesting enough
for us very interesting for us because
particularly for us on the west coast
many of of the whitest pieces actually
evolved in very dry
soils with high salinity and high this
is pressure for piercet disease yeah so
potentially a source of biotic
resistance and as well as a biotic
stressor tolerance
so remember this we look in our invited
species so these are the issues an
interfertile okay so means that they can
cause and hybridize
and that's what I presented you at the
beginning so what we did what actually
Andy Walker the building department did
over decades was to travel across the
western states Southwestern States and
collect collect uh guidelines
these gravis are
very few actual pure species they're
mostly hybrids between the species I
have highlighted there so he collected
them brought back to Davis planted them
in a Vineyard and now we have them
available for genotyping phenotyping do
all the association study we want to do
and we're funded by the pgrp program at
NSF to look at Evolution on these
populations
um in particular in function of piercing
disease this is a bacterial disease that
you don't have here but it's very
important for us on this part or
southern western parts of the country
because it eventually kills guy Vines so
is a major scare for the industry
um and the first thing we did because of
the coexistence of of population of
these different species over time either
in the past or in the present was to ask
what is the degree of integration so
much how many times we find genes
belonging to another species in that
session we're looking at removing all
the all the evidence hybrids can we find
about
um let's see in KBS about 200 KB
integration across across the different
species with of course an impact on on a
number of genes so this means that has
been gene flow Gene exchange across
across populations and eventually we
look at the genes
at least in Arizona deriving from these
integration processes they are enriched
for resistant genes so it seems like
that over thousands of years uh great
population build exchanging genes and
those genes have been acquired and fixed
over time because potentially adaptive
to the in this case disease or other
stresses so said that when we think
about so going back when we think about
Association mapping
uh in this type of germplasm I will
argue that having having a single genome
as a reference could not be enough for
two reasons one the structural
variability across succession within
species is Big so you may have you know
20 percent of the potentially the genes
missing when you look one variety one
accession or the other and the other
problem is that when you are mapping
looking for genes under qtls for example
on a genome
that does not include the intergressed
regions then you will miss those genes
so the idea was to generate a vitis pan
genome and this is a structural pan
genome so we actually use the
functional graph Builder approach and we
selected
a species
pure species of the purest accession we
could find that represent most of the
diversity within the general plasma we
collected
and and here this is
something that it doesn't really
surprises very similar to what we
observe anybody building panchino with
absorb which is the more genome you
sequence the more information you gain
the more information about what we call
the private genome you gain by
sequencing more genomes and one
interesting aspect to this is that when
we look for example the private genome
private genome is highly highly
repetitive so about 70 repetitive
compared to 30 repetitive of the
conserved core genome and and most of
these repetitive uh
increment is due to the uh
disposal elements you can see there
which ones are involved the other thing
is interesting when we look at the
unique
what we call the uh
the private genome and the dispensable
genome so the variable side of the
genome we see a decline in expression
levels
in the size of the genes number of
actions and also in their annotations
okay so this means these are the more
recently evolving parts of the genome
and
um another important thing is uh is
again the association with repeats and
the fact that appear to be more under
positive selection than genes within the
core genome and this is where we are
with the pangino and I will not bug you
more with that
um
I think is as important as a starting
genomes is to make it available to to
everyone because not everyone is
interested in what we're interested in
but genomes are a good resource for
research so these are some
the current status of of everything we
have done both in terms of cultivars in
terms of white species and other
Vitality we're using to study evolution
of sex Etc and they're all um the ones
that we published they're all hosted by
our website in cryptogenomics where you
can find each accession has their own
page
you can download the data and play with
your on your own or use our own tools on
the on the on the server and you know
better than I do about this and we're
trying to update now the
the database or the visualization or the
tools using the new uh um genome browser
that allow us to do more comparative
work linking synthetic regions be able
to jump from one order to another across
across the database and uh um yeah and
that's
possible because of the people in my lab
not because of me of course I'm
I don't do much anymore I wish I was
more involved in actually the
bioinformatics but so for the sake of
today's talk I would like to mention
Rosa Andrea and Melanie are the pillars
of the lab in
wet lab as well as bioinformatics and
helping me with the management of the
lab and uh
in the students and the funding
and thank you very much for the
attention if you have questions happy
thank you
yes
I'm aware of Ford's
great friends breeding programs that are
transitioning to new people and UC Davis
here at Cornell Washington Minnesota
Parlier yeah so this fire hose and new
information how do you uh think that's
going to influence their programs of the
new people
uh I think it's an exciting time because
of that because I I think
um
in two ways
what is available I think is good to
leverage so to start off you know
building you know genotyping platform or
whatever or selecting parental lines in
function what is already out there
and
um because I know all the people that
are being hired
or because now is new generation of net
Network being developed is exciting
because you can work together and I used
to work a lot with Andy Walker because
it was next door and and I'm looking
forward to working with all those those
new people in the community because
um what I do I think you know is
interesting for my own research but it's
much more powerful has an impact if it
is actually used
and I think you know already already the
fact that we move away from SSR markers
and more into to other type of markers
genetic information is is important
um I don't know if Chang is here but a
lot of the work done on Apple type
markets for example is
I don't know much use the genomes but I
bet is having genomes available is
important so yeah
I wonder how much the high amount of
structure of variation poses a problem
in chromosome pairing and if that's why
there's a lot of inbreeding depression
or yeah yeah I think more than anybody
depression which you know is not only
the
yeah you're totally right so there are
multiple levels that to the answer so
one I didn't present this but the degree
of hemisygosity is very high it means it
means we are you're missing the other
allele you have only one copy in the
genome
um
you know that can be a problem if you're
looking at the protein of the inbred
population if you don't acquire a gene
it is important then you may it may not
be viable so I think
we don't know yet but I think he is
August is a huge implication on on
inputting the pressure
um
so that's one the other one is what we
observed over the years is the fact that
certain regions do not recombine
and it's really hard to have dense
uniformly dense genetic mapping in
grapes so something I'm looking forward
to work on is looking the impact on
recombination of of the structural
variability between homologous
chromosomes because I I bet that some
regions you know we don't have markers
are getting because they you know
they're not
because of social variability but we
don't I don't have the piece of
information it's the theory right now
yeah yeah
um you mentioned about it yeah it is
sorry perhaps like I lost that so what's
our identity of the episode
yeah identity with what with uh
transcription factor or what kind of the
identity of the team
and it's the most similar one is that
the yab3 from arabidopsis which that's
why we call it is
because of homology yeah
an arabidopsis has been shown to
participate when mutated to the
morphological development of flowers so
we're we're not surprised but again just
looking at the two alleles we cannot
explain why the male allele is an effect
in the female that's not
by just a single nuclear change a result
in a single amino acid change but I will
have the transgenic suggested the melale
is a good another thing we observe the
yabies are known to cause curling when
you over Express them on leaves
and we can correlate quite well the
expression of the yabby we over Express
with coldness outside of the flowers
which
good evidence that there is a allelic
effect and also an expression effect
so we have a question from Geneva have
you noticed genome uh synchronicity in
gene expression in hybrids any
Divergence in micro rnas
not yet not yet
we have data sets of allylic specific
expression but we never looked in detail
that's how you know one genome May
contribute to highest pressure versus
the other no that's yeah I would love to
to know yes yeah same thing with Mal
organized
but happy to collaborate instance
yes
and do you have an idea given that with
the size of the core Genome of Vitus is
like how many genes are the relative
sizes of the dispensable yeah so I can
tell you every time you compare two
cultivars
we stick to winifery compared to
cultivar you have about a thousand genes
you cannot find
that's typical in inflation of what we
call the private because as soon as you
are the third cultivar the private goes
down and you increase the variable one
the variable is what is shared but not
by all right so I would say a thousand
thousand gene on overage but if you look
in the Chardonnay paper I think it was
about 15 percent of musicality zinfandel
we were around eight percent
so it could be that it varies it could
be that it varies also the Clone you
choose may have an impact the history of
the Clone the how many times the Clone
has been undergone vegetative
propagation and maybe lack of phenotypic
selection as well
did I answer you yes
uh the the core genome that the virus
Gen 2 program
um
uh did
I guess my question is uh
and that's that's the one that allowed
them to do markers you know uh you know
how much
how much the record you know how much of
the overall genome does that represent
well Chang should answer this question I
was not involved in that project 10 but
that ten percent the challenge of that
core map is that it really spends vitis
so it's not only white is vinifera and
and uh yeah I don't know if it was only
structure also sequence based the the
filtering
that you use
Chang is 10 percent
95 of the genome but weighs are spacing
like 200 KB so yeah you have a spaces
between the markets yeah so it's a
uniform but
expense and so in terms of structural
then how much it covers if you sum up
all the structurally
like it covers 94.5 okay but
it's free like it's decreased to uh 20
percent yeah
yeah
that's that's the issue so when you
think about that's just a maybe
disclaimer and also when you hear about
pan genomes
It's tricky because the filtering that
you that you use has a tremendous impact
on what you call variable specific or or
core
um
so always you know when you read the
paper look for that information because
you could be the two papers are not
comparable because the the underlying by
informatics is very different
is
um question on the breeding site with I
understand that and like when you grow
grapes there's certain groups on the
market that like accepts certain
varieties and only want to use this do
you see any change to that are like
consumers like they may want to ask them
I think I think we talk about it but
yeah
so I mean we're going to be at lunch
we can talk about that
I think
um
there is interest
you see an increase in interest for
cultivar so no no new material you know
think about the gem Plaza the benefit is
about three thousand to five thousand
cultivars around the globe you know
so plenty of diversity ready to to to
choose from without having to breathe
um
California we go uh 95 of the time seven
varieties
and most of the time of that is
cabernetes chardonnay
so when I when I'm telling you there is
more interested is really marginal but
by talking to people in the Napa Valley
Sonoma Etc there there is you hear more
about southern Italy Italian varieties
Southern spaniel varieties Greg variety
has been tested for you know
because the future of California doesn't
look great I mean you think about
drought and the heat Etc heat waves and
so it makes sense already to you know we
should have probably done it before at
least have the general plasma out there
and be able to identify which which is
more adaptable but you can already you
know predict what would be more
adaptable than the the varieties that
actually grown they're very domesticated
or selected in the Bordeaux region with
the maritime
heavy rain in summer weather which is
quite different from our so so there is
the interest there is of course interest
from from uh by the industry on on new
cultivars that in that have some
tolerance to disease
um
again what is the what is the
acquisition yet yeah
there is I would say looking
internationally probably there is more
interest right now in Europe
because of uh Downey mildew and copper
use limitation by the European Union
but still
is marginal I mean is
it also be replant every 20 years so
it's not that we one day to another we
start replanting everything and in
adopting your culture I I would say that
you don't get rich being a wine gripe
cultivar a developer waiter maybe table
grapes and yeah tablet companies do very
well because there is much more
replanting and consumers don't care
about the variety they care about the
taste shelf life and
um
yeah so I would say there is hope but
it's a very slow process and
unfortunately you know when you deal
with perennials
uh it takes time and if you don't you
know you have to plan 20 years ahead of
say to answer the question that the
industry will will need
yeah
didn't want to add anything to them
oh only that uh uh why this benefit
didn't co-evolve with powdery music
and so uh it requires us here in our
climate to spray Chardonnay 13 times and
wouldn't you rather as a great Brewer
have a variety that you only have to
spray twice
that's the silly message what is the
answer yes yeah yeah good but then also
so that's the thing you know you know I
I hate to say this but in California we
got a really stuck with Cabernet
Chardonnay because we did pretty good
and Chardonnay
um but it doesn't mean that everybody
has to cultivate cabernetes I mean if
you have good hybrids get go for them I
mean as as much as you don't need
Chardonnay or reasoning Riesling
probably does well here but I think
there is plenty of opportunity of
innovation and unfortunately that
Innovation is not happening at the pace
we need
or at least outside of the labs
thank you guys
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu